vous avez un dossier vous sur quelqu'un
de la table le buteur benjamin castaldi
balance bien le dossier sur kelly mais
que je garde pour plus tard non du tout
maintenant on gardera pour plus tard il
duplique maxime a lâché d'affaires enfin
enfin mon frère est sur les rangs votre
frère joe contraire on est efficace et
là je vote flamand il a 27 ans ce quoi
il est sûr qu'il y aie avait déjà conçu
non il est pas encore
ferriol brad pitt on dirait moi d'abord
et après bad télé mais ce soir là c'est
vraiment pas loin
comment ça c'est vous avez les deux même
pas décrire ce qui s'est passé mais on
aimait la mère sa grand mère mais on est
amer goût amer aux petits la badea non
mais n'a jamais beaucoup plus beau quoi
beaucoup plus beau tu donnes une
répartition optic 2000
franchement ils appâtent honda daniel
s'est passé votre succès de mec ou pas
c'est quoi le style de mec vous lui et
giovanni takeri ou daniela tu peux pas
tout fait savoir n'est trop beau
quoi c'est vrai c'est votre came alors
qu'alice et brett dawson il est très
beau et puis je les ai vus en vrai il
encore plus beau et alors mais les faits
on va voir on mange ensemble ce week-end
normal à balaguier dit la mission de sa
gueule pour j'avais très beau c'est
gentil mais je passais mon week-end avec
kelly ann on était chez moi elle va
passer dix mois papilles il a il va
passer un merci l'orphelin audika juste
au droit voilà c'est tout alors non je
te dis est ce que vous avez à dos sur
quelqu'un ou parce qu'on fait un petit
dossard est ce que tu as à dos sur
quelqu'un oui j'ai j'hésitais parce que
je sais pas si c'est une bonne pour les
deux sessions sans fluor dit y'a pas
vraiment vous êtes sérieux bien sûr
regardez lille a dit le dos on s'en fout
bon ok alors balances ton pote lancement
mais divine m'a fait des petites
confidences et quoi vraiment mais non
bas rappelle ça à propos de cyril non mr
[Applaudissements]
exiger la présence de mon avocat
voila voila sais pas si je pouvais le
dire mais voilà livide m'a avoué qu'elle
avait un petit crush pour vous serrer
mon nom mais ne font rien du tout de
tous mais kelly mais c'est ma copine
[Applaudissements]
divine mais alors alors les deux
monnaies risquées à lemé l'amicale cyril
un moi aussi ça me canadas amical ça me
rassure c'est oui n'est pas amicale du
tout jetable
non mais attendez non mais où on est on
est pas des deux on est tous les voilà à
bach et bien c'est ce à quoi bon se
méfie mais qu'est ce qu'elle veut celle
là les salons de la chine
ça n'empêchera mais je plains votre
frère et moi vraiment si non non non un
prêche en tout bien tout honneur
alors voyez vous dire alors moi je vous
trouve magnifique ici franchement vous
auriez pu être mon délire
rapproche seller malheureusement vous ne
l'êtes pas mais ça tombe bien arriver
sur daniel mon bébé ça va très bien ton
délire mon prêt du tout am bien les
blonds toi la rose et bien les brins moi
j'ai pas très petit mais j'suis pas très
grand ah ouais mais tu es toi le mesure
combien toi mais 58
mais il faut quand même que tu le vois
encore combien un minimum combien avec
170 dans 118 la vidange permettre
s'accordent donc très blues ça ouais
magnifique attention quelle ouverture
c'est pas mal de lire alors non mais
j'ai un petit dossier quoi est amoureuse
de lui ma tin
non c'est un programme jean-michel alors
dans quel état lui d'une excuse à leurs
doutes sur quelqu'un d'absolument et un
gros dos si j'ose dire
chaque fois un bail concerne jean michel
mr pas bon alors dans ses sorties de fin
alors c'est quoi c'est un très très gros
dos jean louis m'a confié en était en
été en loge
j'allume a confié s'être fait retirer un
peu de graisse de son popotin pour avoir
un l'insérer dans son engin pour qu'il
soit un peu mais comme vous tu as aimé
[Rires]
java écouter compétitivité vrai j'aurais
été carrément hors norme mais c'est
complètement mythomane et dit que c'est
faux non c'est pas normal mais regarde
ce que vous avez vous sur catalogue
dominer ce que vous avez à dos sur kaka
en vrai michel mercier veut grossir le
sag évidemment pendant vue l'organe ça
ne vous concernera jamais mais pour les
gens qui veulent le faire vous faire
attention parce que ça ne dure que six
mois lui les finances et oui parce que
c'est ma vraie grèce qu'on m'a appris
moi c'est pas de l'acide hyaluronique
pour la grèce que vous mais elles font
dans ça coûte 3500 euros au bout de 6 à
8 mois et sature joli nom et ses jolies
mains gantées post balader le cisi à
l'air dans ce processus
bon pas tout de moi c'est vraiment
amusant qu'un dos faut pas attendre
d'accord très bien merci
est-ce que vous avez un doute sur tps
gens me traitent en train avait choqué
la non daniel non et c'est vrai nom
joseph c'est vrai mais c'est vrai la
peene plastie ça coûte 3500 euros
alors voilà c'est c'est très bien fait
c'est une petite canule dans la vraie
paix non parce qu'en fait c'est parce
qu'ils sont allés les chercher vous avez
un doute sur qui opposa deux sur kelly
un arrêt à dos sur kenny ado s'est
recalé à dos assez gourmand quoi elle
aime les tartes aux fraises
alors j'ai pas envie de tizé sur le
scoop de sur le dos de maximy je suis
sûr que c'est pourri nous c'est pourri
oui bien sûr comme à chaque fois
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est bien
l'ex et je le fasse mais ben ali et à
sebourg systématiquement de ghettos
avant que chaque émission
elle va récupérer des bonbons elle se
goinfrent en deux temps trois si c'est
bien fait de préciser d'où est-ce que
vous avez un doute sur quelqu'un mathieu
un quoi rien de sûr mathieu as assez
croustillant ouais ça ça me fait un dos
qui pose problème au sein de l'équipe
noba ses excuses année alors depuis
quelques semaines à savoir que matthieu
delormeau a repris la confiance ah oui
mais c'est vrai que là c'est vrai voilà
quand vous êtes d'accord et il a une
nouvelle tactique que je vais vous
exposer parce que vous êtes du 6 au
détriment de tout le monde
moi je suis dupe mais oui après les
émissions moi je suis dit hé oui vous
allez voir devra honnêtement vous allez
voir pourquoi
après les émissions vous restez discuter
avec le public oui non remontants loges
on se change et on s'en va
oui et mathieu lui il se démaquiller il
se cache et qu'est-ce qui fait il attend
que vous remontiez on vous entend
remonter vous par les cris sort de sa
cachette ils foncent sur vous ayez vous
dit j'ai vu plein de fois a vu bébé j'ai
encore fait une bonne émission soir
voilà et vous vous lui répondez parce
que vous êtes d'un naturel gentil oui
c'est vrai mon bébé ouais et là-dessus
revient nous voir en loge est les
connards cyril m'a dit que vous étiez
nul heureusement que j'ai sauvé les
missions chez moi mais je vois pas où et
l'ineptie la mer si mon chéri on
s'accroche à deux chiffres les lèvres à
regarder le écoutez le non non non non
c'est vrai qu'il fait ça mais oui je
confirme à 1,5 me balan merci vous une
voiture comment vous entendez les jours
à mon pote je suis là je suis assad
connaître son prénom
[Applaudissements]
sur l'échelle du boulevard de 1,17 et
largement à 16 merci à tous et j'ai vous
aussi d'aborder la répartie procès de
l'opposante fascicule de maxime c'est
que sa peine ne te laisse le marché sur
les pattes
bravo maxime qu'elle répartit bim
c'était prévu danielle hawey et moi
j'adore de leurs maux non c'est vrai
mais rageux l'adorent pas vraiment ah
ouais lourd quoi est super sympa gentil
et tout ah oui mais vous l'avez vous
vous êtes sûr vous confondez pas c'est
pas de préférer matthieu delormeau ah
ouais quoi c'est vrai ah oui web et les
autres noms noms là d'accord je vous
fais mercure arthur c'est bon de nous
assurer d'avoir le roi ou moi merci à
tous pendant les 2 pieds cloud oc sur
quelqu'un a bon dos et isabelle êtes un
de ces soirs un tout petit truc sur
jean-michel si j'ose dire allez-y c'est
quoi heynckes vous me regardez le mois
manon ma mère là bas
[Rires]
ouais l'école est aussi de dire des
conneries pareilles
non je suis comme ça je crois qu'on a un
bec en fait je crois que je regarde un
dos mais la barre je suis myope de
neuilly permettra de l'eau donc des fois
j'ai dû m'ajuster à thé permettra
d'atteindre une meilleure était à m tu
vois que ça verdier je veux dire il
permettra de dire ah ouais bah il voit
pas elle voit pas de prêt il permettra
pensée presbytie ces princesses bien
mais aussi moins possible d'accord merci
alors oui oui ménagers non c'est
monsieur louis le ya quinze jours en
loge alors qu'on les aime tous mort vaut
pas sur mon jeu un bisou de la 15e jour
en loge alors que personne ne lui
demande d strictement rien vous avez
volé les pattes d'un caniche alors qu'on
lui demande d strictement rien
jean-michel à baisser culotte elle nous
a montré son recto verso plutôt son
rectum verso non ces places et j'ai pas
tout mais je vous garantis que quinze
jours seraient ensuite toujours pas
remise
il ya une sorte de fil rouge quand même
souvenir fort heureusement que j'étais
pas là dans la loge
oui jolie jour s est dit mathieu sevin
dossier super nous la donner non je peux
de neige pour donner un petit peut-être
sur ludivine banon alors sérieux tout
mais c'est une coquetterie mais comme
elle sait évidemment que je te rapproche
de vous et que je suis avec vous
décisionnaires de qui sera au tour de la
terre l'édition 2010 les décisionnaires
des salaires de juste à quelle heure il
va rentrer chez lui vient d'arriver dans
la bande qui évidemment elle veut
s'intégrer peut-être un peu trop
rapidement avec manque de finesse et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont elle passe son
temps sur twitter ami intime de leurs
moeurs ufan de bt de l'ordre et de
compliments sur compliments dans la loge
elle met même invité à dîner alors
qu'ils aient encore d'or pour sa gueule
satis corinne pour dire la vérité avec
qui s'est ténu l'entraînement alors et
ben merci rossi était pourri
merci